Hey, I'm ready
My name is Bailey and this is my boy Ethan you enjoying the breeze boss dog
I've lived a lot of lives. There's a lot of different dogs, but I always found my way back to Ethan. Ow
That isn't getting any easier that is getting it easier, this is CJ the greatest new addition to our pack
Hmm there's nothing in that Cup. I love mornings with our granddaughter
So did I mostly because she gave me bacon. Do you ever taking a bath with the filthy dog?
Oh CJ's mom wants to play too
Or not
Pretty soon CJ had to move away once don't worry you wind up
I wanted to chase the car, but I just didn't have the energy
So much
Take care of CJ. She needs you like I needed you and then it happened
I was a puppy again and CJ was my new purpose
She was a gigantic baby now
It it you have to be the authority well young what is she saying no idea
CJ I have a date tonight again, I could always tell when my girl needed me when you
As soon as I can I'm getting out of here then I'm going to New York City
Wait, I smell my boy
It's me. Really? Thank you
What makes you think you can just show up like this? We want to see our granddaughter, please?
You just keep taking care of CJ
Big dog, you didn't get up for anything no matter how many lives it took I would go there for CJ. Oh hello
Where did you come from? Like he chose you?
Things don't always turn out as we plan. But sometimes the surprises are the best part Roger drum, baby. Don't stop beating
There's lots you don't know about that
I don't have all the answers
But I know we end up where we're meant to be like a drum my heart never stops beating for